[Music]
big news
oh boy guys we are here with breaking
news outside of e Barrett pretty man
pretty man courthouse in DC Trump is
about to be indicted today arraigned and
here is a huge protest right outside as
you can tell this is a live feed from
outside the court things are really
heating up there passions are flaring
Hassan
yeah this is a wonderful showing for
Donald Trump it seems like uh you know
the time is right uh certainly doesn't
say a lot about uh the waning support
for the president the real president of
the United States of America as we all
know the Patriots are rising up and also
helping one another hold on there's two
of them now wait a minute flag this is
breaking news ladies and gentlemen they
have doubled the number of protesters
have instantaneously doubled that's
right there's a third person is that
also a protester we don't know now what
is happening here son they seem to be
changing the flag is this a protester
who's taken the flag down in protest it
doesn't seem so because he's got a Maga
hat on it they flipping it out for a new
flag what do we think is happening I
think uh what's going on is that the
flag was upside down right and and now
they're they're fixing it
so it's no longer upside down that's
what I believe that's what's going on
um my man has dripped out the Wazoo
that's right as you know Trump
supporters are like that uh oh he's
making the poll longer okay good in
order for everyone to see
now it is there it is
Freedom Reigns right here
24. at the E Barrett Prettyman state
court or United States courthouse guys
and I hope that their security is double
triple quadruple down they need to be
prepared for anything I'm seeing a
second flag coming in second flag has
hit the building a second flag coming in
Ethan that's right is there a second
Poll for the second flag question Hassan
I don't see a second pull out there but
it's possible perhaps that another one
of their accomplices will be bringing a
poll although I see they've cleverly
um okay the protesters have tripled in
size and there's a woman now this is
alarming this is alarming are the state
are do we have the Congress police
involved whose jurisdiction is this this
is Trump or death this is a bad Omen for
what's to come later today that's right
1776 to 2024 as in that's when the
American government is over that's the
that's the last year of exploration the
grave stuff yeah because Trump is not
going to be president it seems well this
is a live feed as I said and that is a
serious uh that is serious uh we will be
checking in periodically to make sure
that everything is going well everything
is under control and to bring you live
breaking Updates
this is getting more and more sad
like it's
every single time he gets indicted Trump
is the most indicted man in America
we're back we're back by the way two
weeks in a row they said yeah I'll be
honest with you what there was a chance
last night that I wasn't gonna come wait
what I did I'm here obviously but my
throat was just fine oh my God no reason
and I thought I was gonna have to go to
urgent care oh my God but I I am here
I didn't want to I was like I don't want
to do that you know that'd be horrible
but it would have been crazy
especially because things are heating up
and uh more importantly than things
heating up with Trump's legal troubles
there is a story that I read briefly on
stream yesterday and in my mind I
thought I cannot wait for Ethan to see
this story The ghouliani the Rudy
Giuliani story is so is it's like Taylor
Made for you I don't know how else to
describe it so Dan told me about this he
said please don't look at the new
transcript and I've been good on my word
I haven't looked at it I only saw one
line from it on Twitter immediately that
closed it was something like Rudy saying
bring those tits over here it's uh oh
there's so much more and should we just
get right into it no no well let's let's
I mean don't we don't we know I can't
look because my laptop is not working
but don't we have a like a like an intro
running the show type thing we sure do
this is our show we can do whatever the
[__] we want what's my password
I thought you guys changed that sucks
um let's see what do we got here oh
okay oh yeah you've been in some gossip
some controversy with the reacting well
not really as a matter of fact I I for
the first time in my life uh I am not
like the beacon the victor of hatred for
all things Twitch streaming it's it's
now xqc so congratulations
thank you xqc for finally being a guy
that like people yell at when they think
of like oh twitch streamers [__] suck
well to be totally honest with you dude
um I don't like xqc I think he sucks I'm
just I don't care anymore
I mean he's definitely and he's
definitely an interesting figure he's an
infringer he's a
sellout
and um I think he sucks
you know
he sold his fans out big time for some
goddamn gambling money
so so what is the conversation happening
right now
um the conversation I believe started
around uh lamino's new JFK assassination
video that specifically covers The Book
Depository aspect uh and I'm actually
very excited to see uh all the other
angles as well like specifically the
grassy knoll
um he's just covering the JFK
assassination which is uh probably one
of the most covered assassinations of
all time it's an incredible conspiracy
um
and uh he did this like one hour and 25
or one hour and 30 minute like brilliant
super comprehensive incredibly well
edited video and of course everybody
reacted to it it was trending he's got
millions of views on the video now and
then
um people got like someone got very mad
that xqc had reacted to it as well and
it like only had like 10 additional
minutes of run time off of the original
video and they just like posted a
screenshot and were like what the [__]
is this guy doing you know did he upload
it to his YouTube channel
um I believe he did yes that's [__]
crazy I um and and you know a lot of
twitch streamers do stuff like this uh I
yeah I mean I reacted to it as well a
lot of the same people that were yelling
at him were also trying to yell at me
and be like he's the same he's he Hassan
does this as well and
um and it didn't take comfort in his
well there's a couple different reasons
I mean look I'm not gonna be like oh
he's not reacting hard enough or it's
not transformative enough I don't know I
haven't watched his reaction or anything
like that well we can't did he take it
down
um no I I don't know what happened I
don't even think lamino personally has
said anything about it or has like
uh uh Struck it or anything like that
but he hasn't taken it down hold on let
me look I haven't I haven't paid
attention to the xqc side of things but
the very same uh people that have been
like making this their lives mission to
just
you know criticize react content in
general especially twitch streamers and
how they're like uh technically uh the
same as like rapists doing sexual
assault if they're doing uh reacts to
YouTube videos they were they were up in
arms about it
the problem is like there is uh well not
the things that I just mentioned but
there is certainly truth to some
components like of the criticisms
overall that have been swirling around
about react content
um I myself have absolutely been
uh someone who is is
has broken some of those boundaries but
I usually try how did which boundaries
did you break um one of the things is I
think you'll agree with this as well is
just like don't leave the video running
when you get up not 100 yeah you can't
that's like pretty basic stuff you stop
doing that I only do it with uh I
usually only do it with my uh videos
that I know are from my friends like
Noah Sampson uh second thought things
like that and if you do not have my
permission to walk away from the record
I'm not I'm not actually walking away
for any Center period of time like what
are you supposed to do if uh if there's
an emergency and you have to just say
wait I'll be right back yeah you can
well that and also you can pause it but
the problem is yeah pause the video when
you pause the video it's just like makes
uh the content awful you know what I
mean yeah but like
that's no I'm just telling you no no I
know you're right you say guys put on a
song or something you know I mean you're
absolutely right you're 100 right you
should just throw up a BRB screen
um or I should just online waiting I
mean I go to the bathroom all the time
it's like hey guys I'll be right back
you know what I mean yeah
um over the course of an eight hour
stream though of course that happens way
more frequently than you would uh you
know because
it's about it's about filling it it's
about filling that space a little bit
better you could plan something ahead of
time you could film something to play
when you're there that's entertaining
you know what I would I
what I thought about doing what I
started doing a little bit is like I'll
play
a complimentary video that is like off
of Instagram or Tick Tock or something
that's what I started uh that's what I
started sneaking in if I need to like
get up for a second so it's not the
original video that I thought was a
pretty good idea he plays like
highlights from his stream or something
when he has to go walk away that's a
that's a IRL stream you can do that on
your IRL streams like you have a readily
available clips that you can just like
play the highlights whenever it goes
into low bandwidth mode
you so you can do it on uh desktop as
well I don't know if that's a newer
thing but yeah so I will say this I mean
so that's that's one aspect of it that I
agree with that I'm an offender of as
well
um back in the day especially I used to
I used to have a setup where I would
cook
simultaneously I didn't have a camera in
the kitchen but I would cook but I also
had a monitor in the kitchen so I would
watch the video and I would run back to
the desktop to pause it if I wanted to
say something about it but it was bad
optically I see yeah it was bad
optically people got very upset so I I
recognized that I was wrong I stopped
doing that but now you know you'll
you'll still catch me getting up because
I have to pee or I have to take Kai out
for a second or whatever but I don't
cook
I get my food delivered here's what I'll
say I mean I've been watching your
YouTube channel for a while and your you
the the videos that you or your editor
whoever uploads to YouTube
are very highly edited oh yeah and
totally I think totally fair one million
percent that's the other aspect of this
that I was gonna say we're talking about
like live reacting on Twitch versus
packaging content for YouTube the way I
see it is everybody does react content
like you do react content as well in
certain respects where like we are all
all art is derivative we're all looking
at other people and like maybe doing
commentary all every aspect of the
commentary sphere is react content
um the way I shoot my live streams
is I have YouTube in mind so every
single video that I react to that is a
YouTube video I know I could turn into a
YouTube video personally but given the
aspect and the limitations of live
streaming uh it's not going to be as
Punchy so there's going to be dead air
sometimes or sometimes I'm gonna get up
uh and and have to take care of an
emergency you know what I mean
but
if it's if it's appearing on YouTube if
it's on any of my owned and operated
channels I have four everything else
that you see is not mine right
um it's never going to be uh outside of
the bounds of fair use I mean here's the
difference between your channel and xqcs
which I'm looking at now this man
uploaded five videos in one day there's
no [__] way that anybody's putting
any effort into this like here I watched
this video Andrew Tates you could you
could have multiple editors I mean I
have multiple downloaders let me see
this video Andrew takes controversy of
finally caught up with him I watched
this video so let me see from a police
right on their mansion resulting
huh and of course an x2c wouldn't care
about uploading this because he doesn't
have any moral uh well okay but yeah
you're watching like Andrew Tate's
controversy finally caught up to him
that's not necessarily like a
like this isn't even uh I think the most
awesome go ahead what are you saying
it's not what this isn't even that bad
like you're how do you know I just
started it because no matter what it is
it's probably like a is it just a bunch
of news reactions no it's a video oh
it's just one singular video just one
video I know because I watched it this
is the end for Andrew Tate I watched it
from internet art uh
Anarchist yeah it's not oh [__] oh
that's the guy Andrew internet Anarchist
ironically is the guy that uh [__]
Aiden Ross copy strike because uh false
copy strike because he thought he was my
mod yeah okay guys
so like I mean just right off the bat
what the [__] is this editing there's 10
seconds of him sitting there like a
[__] look at this idiot
yeah I mean it's not it's not high
effort no no it's this is not high
effort I mean hold on no it's not let me
get let me get a taste of this why
wouldn't they cut that
Kristen Tate being held in a Romanian
jail cell for over look at him yeah I
don't even know what the [__] he's
watching I think the main the main
problem here [__] dude the main problem
here should be that if this is on your
main Channel you should definitely edit
it more for sure hold on Asana I really
want to see I want to get a feel for
this but
but with the recent developments in
their case it seems like this is just
the beginning hi I'm the internet
Anarchist I create weekly YouTube
documentaries I mean this is already
theft he didn't and he didn't even intro
it he didn't talk about it he's
literally just sitting there quietly for
the first 30 seconds you should sue him
[__] you xqc you Thief [__]
um I'm not surprised he's stealing
people's videos he steals people's money
yeah
by the way is look you're you're talking
to someone who I do not care about IEP
in the same way that you do we have
differing opinions on it you don't you
think that you should be able to take
people's videos and re-upload them I
sell well not necessarily I think not
necessarily I think you should still uh
abide by certain standards but overall I
don't really care I don't really care if
someone rips my IP I don't know you're
talking about IP law are you talking
about what your preferences my personal
preferences and what I think uh
uh my personal purpose preferences and
what I believe and how I believe IP
should be run is significantly more uh
okay that needs to be run how should I
please be run I think that uh there
should be a uh
there should be a similar structure to
how patents are supposed to exist for
all content creation that
um after a certain amount of time has
passed for like Television Productions
or for uh even movies in general
um that IP should be completely lifted
and you can make derivative Works off of
that with ease that's like a 50-year
scope not even 50 years ago but I think
it should be shorter than that
okay that's number one uh number two I
think that uh as far as like rigorous
control over IP
um I personally don't have it I don't I
don't believe in it I don't think it's a
good what do you mean you don't believe
in it I don't know what that means I I
think so you think that people should be
able to steal your videos and upload it
yeah which is why I have why how is that
fair to anybody
do you really believe that yeah
um Ethan if you literally search
hasanabi there are a thousand channels
pretty much that I literally take every
everything I do on my stream and
re-upload it I know they make money no I
know that you don't care yeah I'm
talking you're talking about like the
law
in a perfect world I don't care that
much either about what people do with
Michael yeah but I'm in a perfect world
I think that uh content of this sort
would uh would be heavily subsidized by
government subsidies in the Arts yeah it
would be subsidized everyone every every
type of content creation would be
heavily subsidized so that it would not
be art would not be created I don't
think of like into like a realization
yeah which is why I'm saying my own
idealistic uh understanding of the world
versus what is happening in the real
world are two separate issues or two
separate scenarios so you believe that
IPS
people should just be able to steal your
content I don't know well first of all I
don't even consider it theft because
people do that already and I have given
allowances for people to do that however
I'm not saying people are stealing your
content yeah I'm talking about IP laws
in general
I think that the protection should only
exist for uh you know people like
YouTube channels and whatnot people that
are smaller uh independent operations
and that the restrictions should be
heavily heavily limited for larger
corporations so how do you decide who's
a smaller and who's a larger that's
actually a really good question I don't
have an answer for that I've thought
about it a lot but I do not have an
answer for it I don't know I I think
like maybe Revenue structure wise like
after a certain so what you just hit you
just hit yeah you just hit the money
number and then you tap and then it it
limits down like a progressive taxation
structure where it like basically limits
the amount that you can maintain uh your
own intellectual property patents what
if you that's how you make a living so
they take your AP ipoa and then all of a
sudden your business goes bankrupt
because everyone can steal your content
what do you mean why would your business
go bankrupt your business potentially
you're making money by creating a
proprietary or unique content okay so
once you were like hey my business is
doing great I'm making 10 million
dollars a year and then you lose your IP
um how does that make sense
because it's it's still unique content
creation which means that just start
re-uploading it and then you're then
your bottom line is going to get crushed
yeah you will you'll certainly well on
your old library content on your old
library content you would still have
like some you see that this is so much
more complicated yeah it is 100 yeah
yeah why make things more complicated I
don't understand that well I mean I
think this is still the way that it
currently exists is still pretty
complicated it's not that complicated
it's like I mean the only complication
is complicated people people abuse the
MCA you know this already like people uh
there are like I that's not common even
even in the way even in the way that I
have simplified my structure where I'm
like do whatever you want uh make money
if you want off of the content even then
there are Bad actors for example there
is a network of like botted channels
from Vietnam that until like I don't
know three months ago were like
uploading videos about phishing that
then turn around and start uploading
videos of my streams
that but that's just okay but that's not
my point is the MCA other fan channels
or even my channel sometimes they try to
dmca meet with my content and they're
abusing the dmca structure it's not it's
not complicated it's just that and you
just need to sue someone to find actual
resolve yeah you you have the law is
pretty straightforward I feel like you
have to have well Bad actors uh are
always going to exist which is why you
need to have some regulations some laws
around it which is what I'm saying I I
agree with you on that
um there's always going to be people
that violate it ultimately if you want
to understand why I have this opinion
look I grew up in Turkey
um we do not have access to uh movies
when I was growing up that in a timely
manner we did not have access to video
games when I was growing up in a timely
manner and the only way I was able to
enjoy all of these video games when I
was growing up in Turkey was uh Cracked
video games was there's a massive black
market
um that was readily available where you
could go and purchase a game in a brick
and mortar retail store that exclusively
sold like pirated material basically
pirated movies and pirated video games
and the only way I had access to uh
anything like the only way I had access
to anything that was going on in the
rest of the world was through purchasing
through a black market substitute
uh Cracked video games and and pirated
movies so sounds like they figured it
out for themselves over there in Turkey
because it was not there there was no
way that you could access it and I still
don't see the solution of making I
everything ip-less
so my point was but that's a violation
of Ip that's like heavily illegal and
good for and I mean I'm not saying that
they shouldn't do that I mean whatever
you know I mean you gotta do so you're
you're like you're fine laws to protect
your [__] okay okay so we're we're
not that far off from one another on
this issue I'm saying that if you break
IP in Turkey you should [__] have
your hands cut off or something I don't
care no I mean first of all there's no
hand cutting in Turkey but I know I'm
just I'm just saying my my point was
that
um
okay so you and I are in agreement on
this then because it's more of a wink
and an odd where it's like Hey listen
you know sometimes you're gonna steal
some movies if xqc re-uploads one of my
videos and just sits there watching I
should have the right to sue him
yeah
so you think that yeah if you well
regardless of my own personal belief I
think that there is still there needs to
still be some limitations to what you
can and can't do because there's going
to be bad faith uh abusers of that
structure is xqc a bad faith abuser I
think xqc is uh working within the
bounds of of
a lack of Regulation around this sort of
thing but it's never it's not going to
be regulated that's that that's the I
mean it is but you again you need to be
sued there's no mechanism there's
perspective on it his perspective on it
is like as long as nobody comes after me
why the [__] would I stop which I kind
of understand because that's how I
approach like uh IP from like MasterChef
for example you know what I mean like
big Television Productions of of shows
that and they could start and they would
be right to sue you I think they would
be in the right I I think so I I yeah I
don't but but I mean I think it's But
ultimately I think that's like kind of
that kind of structure is kind of
ridiculous for example
um here's why
like
as twitch streamers when we're watching
stuff or when we're reacting to things
like we quite literally get paid by uh
either Hollywood Studios to react to
certain things or react to trailers or
even sometimes react to entire uh videos
right like entire episodes the problem
is that given International IP
restrictions when you do that there's a
uh there is a a tremendous amount of
limitation on what you can watch
um you have to geo-lock your content for
example if you are watching anime like
you you might do like a Crunchyroll spot
where Crunchyroll will be like we're
gonna give you money to watch an entire
episode of anime when you do that you
have to geo-lock uh where your content
can be watched you have to abide by
certain sets of restrictions and I feel
like with respect to larger budget
Productions like that the reason why I'm
mentioning the ad component here is
because like obviously
multi-million dollar corporations and
billion dollar corporations see value in
you know someone like a twitch streamer
reacting to their content right
because there is value to it it is uh
you're marketing this material to a
broader audience
um they don't see it as a market
substitute they see it as a good thing
but also on top of that even when you're
assuming they see it as a good thing why
would they give money if it wasn't a
good thing oh no sometimes they'll do it
to promote a show but in the case of
like Master Chef I don't believe
nobody's ever reached out to him and
like you're good to go yeah no no well
but like if if crunchyroll's like yeah
we want to pay you to watch this news
yeah I'm just using that as an example
I'm using like one of the examples to
show you that like yes I think there is
a conversation that could be had about
the value of like watching something
live there of course there's value yeah
but a company decides like hey I want
you to do this the video the entire
gaming industry especially something you
wouldn't normally be watching like you
wouldn't normally sit down and watch a
[__] episode of uh you know
tits out guns out anime or whatever it
is yeah well it's not just Anime uh the
entire
gaming industry relies on uh let's play
as a as a way to Market their product
which is why I'm not saying and then
there are symbiotic relationships yeah
I'm not saying that which is why for
example video games could be subject to
the same kind of dmca restrictions that
um that any kind of content that you
consume online could be subject to I
could I would take it even one step
further
um things that you show like this
the fact that there is a brand on here
that we are not sponsored by but we have
this brand right here this could
technically depending on um I think how
far down the rabbit hole you want to go
like a lot of this stuff is licensed
right licensed imagery we actually
technically don't have the license to
show this I don't know the legality of
that I'm not familiar with that sounds
interesting well I can just interject
from my experience working on like
movies and TV that um everything that
appears in the TV show has to be cleared
yeah everything that's why that's why
they don't show you brands in like a
certain well they're just right not
necessarily because I mean so what
anyway I want to watch xqc [__] I
want I really want to get a sense for
when he starts talking trees and today
we'll be taking a look we're already
watched third uh
how long we watch this [__] thing
see this [__] is such an idiot he's got
the [__] he didn't even edit it I'm
looking at his
I can't tell which is his time bar and
which is the one of the video because
it's so [__] unedited like it's so
you care it's so little this is a
straight VOD rip uh here's he's been
going for 30 seconds the recent news and
developments in the Tate Brothers Saga
following that move from jail to house
arrest on the 31st of March 20.
shut up no man okay no no man he's not
even talking about the video he's
responding to a comment in chat yeah
news and developments in the tape
Brothers Saga following their move from
jail to house arrest on the 31st of
March 2023.00
bro Chad is saying don't watch this
video why are you watching this video
and he's saying I want to know man I'm
an xqc uh I'm an xcc analyzer translator
so let me say let me explain something
here so it's gonna happen on a live
stream that's always okay listen right
now is about uploading this straight Von
rip yeah your YouTube channel right well
there's two prongs there's two prongs
here one
is uploading it to YouTube which is
insane and he should be sued for this
and I hope people do I mean content
creators themselves uh always care about
it which is why not always but when they
do they should have that it's their
right I mean I don't think it's
respectful to upload a video like that
period
at least put a [__] little effort
into make it watchable like what is this
[__] dude [__] does just mean
stupid he's um clearly some content
creators do because they're making us
think about it yeah which is the point
is this okay there's two different
classifications to to have conversations
on one is what you're reacting to on
your Twitch stream
and their standards of practices on that
as well or like what's the most ethical
way to react you can have a conversation
about live stream reacting live stream
reacting and then the other side of the
uh story is uh what you upload to your
owned and operated uh channels to
channels that you own that you have
creative control over
and
um yes I maintain the position that like
things that I upload to my channel to my
YouTube channel have to abide by certain
standards because if it was just
straight VOD rip it would be very boring
and it would be a in some respects maybe
not technically a market substitute but
like not a good uh not a good
representation of like what kind of
content I put out on my own well okay so
there's two prongs the YouTube one we've
covered the twitch one has not really
been tested to be honest with you and
there's a lot I feel like there's a lot
of
listen it the walking away and leaving
things uh playing it shouldn't be done
by anyone on Twitch ever yeah I do it
all the time like there's no I I mean I
I just think you're creating a huge
legal liability by doing that because
one day somebody's going to come start
suing people and if that's up and if
you've done that you have a huge
liability yeah there's no way you can
justify that in like in court
or to a judge yeah playing it uh I guess
like technically the only thing that you
could do is uh
like
from a legal standpoint I'm not even
saying this is like apt or adequate as a
counter
um but maybe like chat uh no I don't
know like having having different all
that proves is that there's people there
[__] consuming the video that you're
not doing yeah you're right
um overall but if you don't care about
overall B that's one overall the reason
why no but overall the reason why like a
lot of YouTubers don't complain about
that in general or but they might and
you're absolutely right about that
um overall the reason why a lot of
people don't complain about that is
because uh they don't see it as a
one-to-one they see it more as like
promotional most YouTubers I
up to the streamer to decide if it's
promotional or not no you're you're
right about that which is why it's more
of like uh
as long as nobody complains about it
you're doing it type which I get it I
get it you guys been watching MasterChef
they don't seem to care that's awesome
yeah but remember when yeah when I was
doing that it was older it was older
Seasons it was never like a new season I
would literally have the contestants on
I literally had them no no I know I know
I'm just saying that like it was still
relatively transformative in the sense
that like even if I were to put out a
final product from that which I never
did that's good that you did um my goal
was always to make it as entertaining as
possible and also on top of that
um have uh you know like literally the
the chefs and whatnot that were involved
uh involved in the content creation
process and the second secondary
Marketplace there there might even be
like more
relaxed analysis for live chat because
or for live streams because it's not
archived somewhere uh but but it's just
not been tested you know but I would
definitely encourage you not to do the
walk away play thing
and and you know if you are watching
something too
to provide
to be you know uh conscious of how much
yeah analysis is going into it which I
think you are
but some people aren't even even if you
look at like fan Channel upload reacts
the one thing that haters are always
confused about is like there's this meme
about me uh the the chair meme right
it's a it's a part of twitch culture
because like when you're live for eight
to ten hours two things that are always
going to happen is like one you're going
to be eating on camera so that's like a
big meme the other one uh about live
streaming in general is that of course
you're going to get up at a certain
point right that that is where that
chair meme comes from which then turned
into like oh Hassan just like well
uh click play and then leave his chair
on and uh and walk away
you do do that though you just said you
do no but there's a difference I don't
let the video just [__] run the
throughout the entire process and just
like walk away and [__] off you did say
you just I get up for I get up to either
take a piss sometimes if I really add if
I really have to pee without pausing the
video which I should I should do like a
BRB screen or something and I'm working
on uh
I'm trying to figure out a better way to
do that by possibly playing something
that like either the person will never
have issue with or rather uh you know
playing like a like a tick tock or
something just like
jiggle some keys uh in the eyes of the
audience so that it's like the content
is not stale so right I'm fine like I
said but at any rate xqc is the biggest
[__] douche offender piece of [__]
ever I literally hate him okay he's so
Vibes like he is he's just the worst man
he doesn't care about anything I think
there's definitely a lot worse people
online than xqc I didn't say he's the
worst person online I yeah he's just
like
he is just doing uh whatever the lack of
limitations and boundaries are it's just
like yeah that's why he's making getting
paid 30 million dollars to play [__]
um
100 steak or whatever 100 million
dollars to play stake I mean that's like
well he's not I don't know if he's
playing steak he is
right I mean I don't think I don't think
he's gambled or maybe I don't know I
don't watch kids why do people watch
this like genuinely let me watch this
now so that's it why men can't get mad
there's another question Ethan people
say that about you and they say that
about me all no but he's not saying
anything
but it doesn't matter some people like
it he is he is very representative of
like front picture the average gamer
group picture to make it seem like he
has friends
a picture in Paris to make it seem like
it's cultured I just want wait pause for
a second
you know what's funny
all of these videos are kind of fire to
react to like I'm I'm watching this and
I'm like damn I should react to this
video just say some [__] and you're good
don't just sit there why men can't get
matches on dating apps like I feel like
that's ooh that would be like an eight
hour video for me I would watch this
[__] 10 minute video and lose my mind
probably
actually climbing mountains to make it
seem like he's adventurous
after some hard work the profile is
ready
the woman doesn't feel safe sharing a
lot of 40 seconds so she chooses not a
single comment or introductory statement
or anything confined no words from him
frankly and she's ready to go
they start swiping and hope for the best
45 seconds
[Music]
at the end of the day 50 seconds her
light counter is full practically every
profile she likes is an instant match
soon she's over one minute matches and
messages in her inbox
for the man it's the difference is he
even watching the video
is he just like looking at a [__]
like one of these cat things I mean I
think he's watching the video he's
probably looking at chat there's a lot
of stimuli when uh you're live streaming
so it's like hard to exactly figure out
what's going on you don't need to defend
him a song I'm Not defending him I'm
defending myself Ethan that's what it is
because like I've gotten the exact same
uh types of criticism and you can
absolutely make the exact same types of
criticism about me if I'm being
perfectly honest the reality is that uh
but you don't upload it to YouTube yes
that's the that's I mean that's a big
difference that's the major difference
if you ever see a video like that on
YouTube it is most likely from a fan
channel that took a straight VOD rip and
posted it on YouTube and is monetizing
it themselves it's not it's not touching
me in any capacity
and can I be honest with you what there
will be a time in my opinion where still
be some legal Hammer that will come down
on streamers and there will be a time
yeah and you guys will look back and be
like damn I missed that was crazy that
we just sat there watching content like
that day will come
when you guys will not be allowed to do
this anymore because it's just so risky
um uh because there will be legal I
agree and so
and so I that's truly what I think but
again
my my criticism of him right now is that
he uploaded this to YouTube
because I understand the nature of live
streaming you sit there stuff is going
on like you said for him to be like yo
okay so this was actually fire I'm not
going to edit it at all I'm gonna cut
this unedited basically their video at
all because there's no because uh
there's never been any kind of I don't
think he's ever gotten criticized for
this even but yeah um he's got [__] for
this up until this very moment there has
never been an xqc is bad for doing this
I'm telling you this because I've been
getting [__] on for years in spite of
the fact that I have like these
boundaries on how I make this kind of
content and what I choose to upload onto
my actual like owned and operated page
that's like heavily edited
um
regardless of that I've been getting
[__] on online for years and years and
not a single peep was ever made about
xqc process and he never [__]
sidestepped to be like hold up guys
let's stop now I mean I do this too it's
kind of ridiculous he's never [__]
come out and like defended me in any
capacity despite the fact that he
himself was uh a a regular abuser of the
same structures uh if we're being real
the same goes for again Charlie moist
critical any kind of asthma gold any
kind of live streamer that is live
reacting to content can always have this
kind of footage cut out uh of them
because they're live for 10. it's the
same I understand that is a big
difference that's why I think the
important thing to mention here is that
uploading that kind of VOD uh content to
YouTube without any editing any editing
whatsoever is not good and it it's uh
it's not a good product in general but
listen
the one the one thing I have to mention
here is that it's no different than when
podcast first came out and people would
get clipped out of context all the
[__] time on podcasts because it was
the first time that we were experiencing
like an uninterrupted three hour uh uh
medium of content from people that were
not media trained to speak for three
hours so you could very easily cat
someone off guard and make them appear a
certain way I don't think you need to
make excuses I mean look just own it you
do that [__] what do you mean you do
that [__] you watch I mean you and all
these guys yeah I feel like yeah I do
that [__] you don't have to like make
Technologies and excuses and stuff
it's not an analogy at all the point is
you have to if we're talking about it
like live reacting if we go back to like
the live reacting on Twitch uh side of
things
I like that there are no legal
limitations to it I think it's a good
thing I know that um and I know you know
that uh the Youtube live dmca structure
is uh definitely ripe for abuse that's
number one and it's the same the UTA
structure that governs twitch isn't it
it's just it's just a it's a set of laws
that you provide platforms yeah it means
automated process and the way that
YouTube has set it up has made it so
that you can like very quickly shut down
uh most uh live productions you could
very quickly shut them down or you can
immediately monetize them I mean you've
had this you've had this issue there's a
reason why like you can't even watch
like a tick tock video because you're
worried that if there's 10 seconds of
like music that slips in then all of a
sudden your three hour content that you
produced with a team of of brilliant
producers and and and put together all
of a sudden is gone because of a of like
a slip up and I don't think that
structure is is good for making I don't
think here I don't think it's like
something they're even really stressed
or or about but I do think like it's
good to acknowledge like yeah we are
doing this thing that's probably not
right and I'm thinking about ways to
better address it because it's like you
said it's the industry standard it's the
norm yeah of how people operate on
Twitch and I do think it's worth
acknowledging that you know in some
cases it's not right which you have done
right yeah and so you know that's what
it is and so I like that there is uh
like a less automated process though I
will admit one because obviously
personally beneficial for me but two I
think it's better
for making unique derivative Works in
general uh it it really limits uh your
creativity it limits what you can and
can't do people can immediately go well
creativity just [__] play a YouTube
video walkway right like no you still
have to consider the rights of the of
the people that made the content but
like and I think the reason that it is
more relaxed on Twitch is because
legally there's more room to play with
because of the whole saving It And
archiving it and putting it up on
YouTube yeah gives a little bit
different playground to play it that's
why I'm being super extra critical of
xqc because look at this [__] and I'm at
one minute this [__] hasn't said
a single word so far he has only
received a couple of likes okay zero oh
here we go he becomes frustrated false
false alarm minute 10. whoa okay
there's so much effort what the [__] is
he even talking about who's he talking
to
setting up a nice bro I could tell you
don't really watch Twitch at all right
listen on YouTube right now dude yeah
I'm saying like I can tell you don't
really YouTube live streaming is very
different due to the uh automated dmca
I'm judging you would not be able to do
this on YouTube judging this as a
YouTube video which is what it is
that's I understand that I know it's
hard for me it's hard for me to separate
the two in my mind because I'm like I
know you you you're feeling defensive
because you feel because I'm looking at
that and I'm like well that's if I was
if I was watching this on Twitch I would
be perfectly understanding that it's a
YouTube video yes that's what I'm
criticizing it's fair yeah
exactly as [__] yeah to answer that
question good comments 120.
I made a simulation of a dating app with
1000 dummies to try to understand why
men get so few minute 30 no commentary
yo because they gotta oh we got a big
screen here it is
guys guys I feel like this is just like
can you just break it break this down
just evolutionary like
it's just like normal like like animal
type [__] dude it's like you gotta
compete bruh can we transcribe that
I feel like this is animal [__] he's
talking he's trying to talk about
evolutionary psychology yeah and saying
that like uh the reason for this uh
disparity on dating apps for men uh
comes from
regret it I mean I understand what he's
trying to say yeah that's what we're
trying to say well you can do all these
tricks and add all these these feathers
that are all these see there's editing
and we got the bird we got the Rolex
it's just it's just a brown bird
because the benefit of appeal the best
video
this part's fine even though I think he
sounds like a [__] it's okay but it
took him two minutes to [__] say a
goddamn single word about it well first
you got to establish your narrative what
are we watching you know what I mean
well he didn't do that well he let the
video do it I think well he needs to do
it I mean you know he's not gonna talk
for two minutes
I mean listen I'm just telling I'm just
telling it like this is what it is dude
this is Adam's video I need to destroyed
a picture of what's a real dating world
is like whatever but yeah more XTC is a
[__]
I I really dislike him I don't care
um
did we did we make any uh uh do we do we
touch any new ground on uh the the
ethics of live streaming I feel like we
we need to summarize it like okay ldr of
it here's what I think I don't think
what you're doing makes you a bad person
or wrong or something that you should
feel guilty or even get dogpiled I don't
I don't even feel guilty about what I'm
doing okay
but what I do think is that
it's good for streamers to start
acknowledging the bound there are
boundaries
and there are certain things you can and
cannot do or there are things that that
make it better and there are things that
make it worse and I think it's good for
react streamers to start acknowledging
those things and trying to work to make
it better
yeah I mean I
as one example I have yeah I've gotten
criticized I've gotten criticized a lot
for this for many many years and uh
regardless of the personal Vendetta or
the genuine interest that like my
interlocutors in those situations had
about like what what whether it be
generating Cloud for themselves or
whatever
um uh even though I very swiftly
apologize for it and and tried to make
amends for it uh and they just refuse to
recognize that and just continued
hammering on for years and years about
how big of a piece of [__] I am uh which
made me drop uh any pretense of trying
to respond to these people all together
there are there are truthful aspects of
their criticism which I've taken to
heart and have changed uh the way that I
live stream even on top of that good
great um yeah I guess like the other
side of this is that if pressure keeps
mounting in this regard towards the uh
live streaming and like live streaming
uploads onto YouTube
I'm gonna have to start cracking the
dmca whip on my own uh Hassan of eclipse
industrial complex like fan channels
right because uh one it's not good
content in general if you're just like
leaving that dead air and if you're not
editing it so to in order to make it
transformative just to be clear you're
talking about not channels that upload
your Clips wholesale yeah not you yeah
vodrips yeah yeah just not me because
you will not find I don't think
I don't think you'll find a video uh
from my own personal Channel where like
I'm not and you won't
like uh watching a video with the
with uh the hope of making it as
transformative as possible I do that for
every YouTube video that I watch for
sure uh there will always be exceptions
to the rule
like I can't uh I can't say across the
board you know
but
uh ultimately
given how much I do add with respect to
the context
if you're a fan Channel out there and
you're like uploading straight VOD ribs
stop trying to go first the market
another thing that they do that's
frustrating is like they'll literally
steal the original art the original
thumbnail and just slap my face on it as
I'm doing like soy face I hate that [__]
you didn't change the song you didn't
change the [__] thumbnail you didn't
change the title you're basically trying
to squeeze into the algorithm and ride
the coattails of a YouTuber who [__]
worked a lot and and spent a lot of time
and effort and money to make a video I
don't like that at all and I tell you
those guys have upset me a few times
where I'm doing one of my interviews and
then they'll upload you reacting to it
before our show's even done
yeah like yeah no they're they're fast
with it and it's like I don't like it
it's like I agree I mean I I have you
told them to not do that uh there are
instances like uh where I'll I'll reach
out to a content creator ahead of time
um to be like are you comfortable with
this if they're not I'll tell ahead of
time like don't react to this don't
upload this or like the people being the
first to Market there but there are
still but there are still
absolutely channels that basically take
advantage of the lack of uh protection
on YouTube not just for me they do it
for Charlie as well they do it for any
twitch streamer like every single twitch
streamer has
every single twitch streamer has like
this
kind of issue where they will literally
go it's people they oh that's one that's
one of them that's literally the channel
I'm talking about that's the [__]
channel it's possibly Capital too quick
click on this channel it's just here
this is a great example it's just an
image oh [__] but I know what it is
because it look it's the whole [__]
thing and it's 130 130 it's the whole
interview and I wasn't even done it was
uploaded before episode even processed
dude and I'm like dude you do that to me
as well and I know it's not used I'll
respond I'll respond to like a Ben
Shapiro video about me right I'll I'll
respond to eventually video about me and
they'll upload it while I'm still
[__] streaming so this blanket like
you guys can upload anything I don't
care is not really working out and these
some rules but but that is a problem
with YouTube though because click on
Google hasanabi Capital too right now
I'm looking at it right now okay
okay here
uh this is a great example right
Okay click on the click on the page go
to videos click on the videos it says
fan channel right you're like whoa click
on oldest
oldest
boom you see this [__] yeah they don't
give a [__] no I can't do anything I've
told YouTube A Thousand Times Like These
are the [__] channels these you know
what these [__] do tell them no
you know what they do you know what they
do they dmca other [__] fan channels
of mine with my Clips so you should DM
State dmca this guy you shouldn't let
him get away with all this [__] like
look at this
yeah and there's not much you can do
about it there's like so many no DMS
YouTube
doesn't care they don't do anything you
have to do it yourself they can't file a
legal claim that YouTube cannot file a
DMC on your behalf
they can't do it okay but if you dmca
him three times his channel will get
[__] suspended or banned you know
what I mean look all that's sudden here
yeah but you realize
hasanabi is about to get me paid yeah
and this is not one channel oh this was
one of his first Clips bro there is so
many 300 000 bill is a network they have
like they operate like a like a bot
Network we've taken but the reason that
there's example is because there's no
accountability I know but we take down
their channels they just make they
literally will go make a new one and
make a new one that's only been
operating for a minute
I think that that's wild because dude
there's so many of these [__] guys
out there they do it to they do it to
other people you don't care I'll do
dmcas when they upload my content like
do it because I was like I said this for
for all YouTubers as well listen dude
fan Channel
it doesn't [__] matter if if you
don't like
if you don't like a type of content you
have it on your dashboard you click on
your dashboard you see you know hasanabi
fan channel right
um and you see like 10 of your video was
utilized here it shows up on your
dashboard right you know you know
exactly who's watching your videos and
when and and who's uploaded your videos
If you see that uh number one if it's uh
if it's a fan Channel they will always
have
uh it will always have an email that you
can send a you know a request to they
will immediately take it down fan
channels will always taken down uh if
you want you can also dmca them I don't
think they need to be punished dmca them
what because here I'm gonna just say
this right now
people that are uploading my content
wholesale because someone reacted to it
and they're especially they're doing it
to get ahead of our video in the in the
algorithm I will dmca you
and I do not give you consent either
which I'm going to dmca these videos
right now do it dmca this [__]
where's the other one there was two of
them right
you sent me two okay we'll do it after
the show but yeah there's a there's a
bunch of channels like this yeah it's
not I'm not saying it's your fault at
all no I know dude this is something
that happens to moist critical as well
for the record it's not just me and and
like YouTube is aware of this problem
they just don't really they don't much
about they don't it's not in their tool
house they have the legal authority to
start removing people's videos for dmca
it needs to be do it for because they
don't own the videos you do I know but
they do it for they demonetize channels
like this for uh what is it called uh uh
uploading content no they they
demonetize channels all the time so
you're not entirely correct on this they
demonetization monetizing is not dmca
dude I know but when these channels get
demonetized then they're done there's no
use for them to exist any longer that's
my point like uh I don't think YouTube
knows what the [__] this channel is [__]
what is it called yeah I know it's yeah
you're re-uploading it's called like
duplicative content or something I tell
people they could upload our clips and
YouTube won't monetize any of them it's
weird that that like they seem for some
reason anyone that uploads your [__] it
gets monetized but like people that were
trying to do it for ours YouTube was
like because I because I don't have an
issue with my Eclipse being monetized I
told them that too it was weird they
wouldn't let me do it yeah well is it
different maybe because the original
content lives on Twitter oh that is on
space that's that's definitely yeah it
was originally posted on YouTube then
and I think they they get you that's it
for sure it's not your fault it's not
your fault sounds like a song current
actually does believe in limits the IP
ripping contrary to how this whole
conversation started yeah exactly except
I mentioned that in the beginning
because I always said there's gonna be
bad faith people
um and that there needs to be some level
of Regulation to deal with bad fate
people which is what I said in the
beginning of this conversation once
again news flash I had a nuanced uh
perspective on a subject matter that I
have personal experience with and yet
people have black and white
understanding understandings of the
subject so they immediately rush to
conclusions on what they think I'm
saying
anyway
um
[__] this guy though for sure
you know what I mean this guy
oh yeah yeah yeah there's there's a
bunch of channels like that so here but
anyway we haven't talked about Trump at
all this kind of went uh I wasn't even
planning to have this conversation uh
but there it is
um you can you make a note Dan I want to
send a dmca to these for this [__]
guy for these two videos he re-uploaded
okay thank you comment for you [__]
right
the bell's stolen for your [__] ass I'm
coming my first dmcas and my whole
goddamn career
maybe there's been a few others of
people re-uploading wholesale
but I'm [__] coming for you
be afraid [__] and I got time
and I got people I'm gonna follow you
new channels no
I'm right on your ass they're out here
looking like Mitch McConnell
on the podium
um goddamn right all right well dude we
have so much to talk about today all
right well so cut to the courthouse
things are heating up out there there's
a goat man boycott Nazi fascist
Singapore Malaysia okay oil fracking
what is the lots of juice stuff message
there what is race can we flip the Kratz
can we mess can we read his sign can we
get a shot of that uh make America
makeup I see a make America's penis
great again with a force oh that's the
penis guy this guy I've seen this guy
before bloody Satan circumcision yeah
he's a he's a he's a [__] uh he's big
in the in the uh the the intactivist
community
it seems like you're oblivious to the
most important issues
there's a community of men who are
trying to grow back their foreskin yes
you're talking about me yes I'm trying
to grow it back dude remember what they
took from us dude yeah yeah
so true you're circumcised does it
bother you penis
um not really I don't really think about
it that much I I wish you I mean I it'd
be better if I wasn't I think do you do
you not feel that way I personally don't
and I I'm not like I think it looks good
I I love my penis I think it looks yeah
I think it looks very healthy and very
happy that's what that's how I feel you
know I'm not I'm not upset about it at
all but I understand again I'm not
saying like I totally understand
people's like the weirdness with it you
know especially just that in America
they just started doing it to everybody
penis you know so I get that I'm not
disagreeing I'm just saying in my
experience I'm cool
would you stand in solidarity with this
man with the goat man okay let me read
this um genocide paying a lot
racist Jews read Jew Bible Genesis
chapter 21 9 10 11 12 13 14. so much
reading things are heating up outside
there
uh this was actually a few minutes ago I
I rewound
um right now there's no one
oh it's empty wow
so
damn okay support out there for trumpy
boy wow heating up
all this full alert all right so what do
we what do we have to watch here let's
see what we actually spent an insane
amount of time on that conversation but
I thought it was a good conversation I
think it was a productive conversation
it was a good conversation it's one that
needs to be added you are the dmca king
you know what I mean and I listen I
don't want people or you to think I'm
like trying to I'm not keeping guilt on
you I'm I'm really telling you as far as
your YouTube channel goes I personally
vouch that it's totally good there and I
think you again the what you do on
Twitch is like the norm so I think
industry Norm is important
and like but I said like I said just you
know if there's things that you know are
wrong then just try moving away from it
just just understand if you're in here
uh I try to do this in good faith um I
do legitimately believe that watching
stuff on Twitch not putting it up on
YouTube I'm talking like specifically
watching stuff on Twitch does have the
capacity to boost the content creators
there's plenty of content creators that
have at least said so to me but
privately and publicly getting
permission is a whole different thing if
you're friends with somebody yeah or if
you're friends and you know they don't
care that's a different that's different
because you if you have someone's
permission a license or permission you
could ever the [__] you want with it or
if you don't have permission
um you better make it as transformative
as possible like yeah Ben Shapiro I I
watch his [__] all the time
there is zero percent chance he's coming
after me why well one because there's an
established understanding in the in the
commentary and politics sphere that that
sort of thing is allowed and two what's
he gonna do be like this is not
transformative I don't let him speak for
longer than 35. you're exactly agreeing
with them by Nature it's transformative
yeah exactly so he's gonna go watch your
video because they want to hear Ben
Shapiro and not you yeah but anyway
let's talk about Rudy because I don't
want to miss the opportunity to talk
about ghoulier uh I've been I've been
staying virgin
on the goalie there's so much stuff we
got to skip over but that's what it is
some Diet some days we just fire off
you know yeah
and that's a beautiful thing it's
disgusting
so um okay maybe so another way you're a
bunch of [__] so what was the context
of all this new Giuliani oh God we're
diving into that because I don't want to
run out of time it's already 11 30.
you're so right let's do it yeah we're
skipping the streamies and
well I wish you know what I mean this
isn't the important stuff okay
so why did it why is it that more info
came out on this transfer okay so Rudy
Giuliani there's an update on the
lawsuit uh as you guys know giuliani's
former aide Noelle Dunphy was suing
Giuliani for sexual harassment while she
worked for him in 2019 and 2020. uh
there was a complaint it's 70 pages long
it's full of claims uh I'm I'm just
reading through some of the the
highlights here the former eight alleges
that Giuliani won made her work naked
made her perform oral sex drank all day
and night made racist remarks made
sexist remarks made anti-semitic remarks
which I can't wait for Ethan to hear uh
didn't pay his bills and sold Trump
pardons for two million dollars and now
at the time when it first came out we
were like oh my God this is such a fat
legal document that like there has to be
there has to be transcripts or there has
to be like full-blown like like physical
evidence to to point to this you can't
just like allege all this stuff without
backing it up because these are some
pretty serious claims right yeah
um well it turns out there are 70 Pages
turns out there are holy [__] audio
there are there is audio footage there's
there's audio audio so Windows tapes
when they're quoting here's what
Giuliani said it's not according to her
it's literally no been recorded yeah
yeah it's a tape yeah oh yes
I want more thank you I want more than
anything yeah it's just like here
uh it's a civil lawsuit so I don't yeah
that applies anyway I might break in
somewhere just again yeah maybe I mean
it's my Watergate that this is my job
turns out Noel recorded many of the
alleged incidents and uh you know some
of them were were read a while back on
this stream as well as everywhere else
just click on the Imgur album okay so I
think it's the lawsuit is 70 Pages it
claims the former eight alleges Giuliani
made her work naked made her perform
oral sex it's not funny I'm sorry I'm
laughing and she's absurd drank all day
and night made racist smart remarks made
sexist remarks made anti-semit
anti-semitic remarks didn't pay his
bills sold Trump pardons for 2 million
let's open it up we knew all that okay
open up the document Ethan open up the
document yeah here it is your honor I
haven't read any of these your honor I
would like to your honor Ethan Klein uh
your Holiness I would like to direct
your attention to image number one from
page two where Mr Giuliani is allegedly
making anti-semitic remarks uh I'm going
to read it in Mr giuliani's voice for
you
[Music]
um
Jews
they want to go through that freaking
Passover all the time
man oh man get over the Passover it was
like 3 000 years ago
okay the Red Sea potted big deal not the
first time that happened really
this this I like to categorize under
it's anti-semitic but it's so creative
that it makes me go is this anti-semitic
are you feeling he's doing a bit because
it's like part of his material because
it's like when has the Red Sea parted
before before accident
but I'll say this um
this man was mayor of New York the most
one of the probably the most Jewish
cities Americans outside of Israel yeah
yeah
yeah there's more there's a whole Jew
anti-semitic section here yeah there's
more there's more Ronnie said the way
the way natural selection Works Jewish
men have small [__]
because they can't use them after they
get married it's a sexual dance what
yeah wait what whereas the Italian men
use them all their lives so they get
bigger I've never heard that theory Jews
have small dicks because they get small
if you if you don't use it you lose it
this is you know what this is this is
like a reverse in cell theory because
like insoles don't know how news flash
they don't know how vaginas work right
so they'll always say like if you have
sex as a woman like your [__] grows
larger and larger and that's how it
works and that's why you need to [__] a
virgin or whatever right an experience
that's gentle caress but this is the
reverse of that
and in a weird way exclusive to to
Jewish men I guess
why don't Jewish men have sex after
marriage I was baffled by that part time
I don't know that's not a thing I even
in reli in like the Orthodoxy the I
think sex between men and wife is pretty
pretty encouraged they have children
yeah so
they'd be [__] dude yeah okay so
there it is Mr Juliana and a reminder
these have all been audio taped yes
these are all from a court appointed
transcriber signed off by a judge that
are all real God I got I got another one
yeah
uh directing your attention to page two
again Mr Giuliani says maybe they each
one blame it on the other one and that's
why they're angry it's like those
freaking Arabs are the ones that's
forcing us to use their sheep and the
Arabs say it's those darn Jews that are
forcing us to use their sheep somebody
should tell them it's Moses and Muhammad
who did it so did you see this stuff
with Biden now they've got pictures of
him in rather compromising situations
touching these little girls little girls
to which Miss Dunphy responds right to
which Mr Giuliani uh responds with he
may be he may really be a weirdo now I
found this really interesting because
well one
um you know I don't know what he's
referencing here with their with you
know psycho speak yeah Arab uh people
and and Jewish people
swaps over to Biden touching children
inappropriately and it's really odd
because
he did that right he literally we saw
yeah him trying to [__] someone he
thought was underage on camera on a
feature film I mean it's really oozing
with irony he's saying while being
recorded for later exposure he may
really be a weirdo as someone's filming
Juliana is going to judge a character on
that to prove what a weirdo
fantastic I like my coffee dark
yes
like I like moss like I like my
man um there's who were the other
Republicans who are celebrities asked
Miss Dunphy Mr Giuliani responds ain't
too many Brad not Brad Pitt the other
guy that looks like him Miss Dunphy says
Bradley Cooper Mr Giuliani says no the
other one what the hell's his name uh
Miss dumpy says well Matt Damon is very
liberal Giuliani respondsman no Matt
Damon is a Matt Damon is a f word Matt
Damon is also 5-2 iser blue coochie
coochie
what the [__] I
what the [__] I will pay
untold amounts of money to hear that
just that secret we need that we need to
hear him say coochie coochie coochie coo
what the [__] was he doing why would
that come out of his mouth I think he's
in almost all of these sloshed like
that's like somebody who's just like
miserably drunk because it's just like
uh Rhymes Gucci Gucci I just it's hard
to imagine like
someone actually just saying that
backwards like that it's hard to imagine
Rudy Giuliani uh sloshed you're right I
guess he seems so he's always been so
put together and Well he seems so
coherent normally yeah Matt Damon I was
thinking Matt Damon's not five two that
means 5 10. shorter than me incidentally
but you're wait I thought you were
aren't you 5 10 5 11. I thought you were
5 10. not since he got the platform five
eleven oh okay okay actually you must
know now we're getting into the good
stuff
um
Matt Matt Damon is five two are you guys
are blue what is this Dr Seuss on
[__] uh
like sex trafficking doctors would you
like to read this next sure I'll take
this one on I'll be I'll be missing
before you Mr Giuliani come here big
tits
wow come here big tits your tits belong
to me
give them to me indiscernible mumbling
I want to claim my tits I want to claim
my tits I want to claim my tits these
are my tits oh yeah
these breasts belong to me nobody else
can get near these cubbies
I don't care if they're flirting or if
they give you business cards business
cards
these are mine you got it yes understand
I'm very [__] possessive I've gone
easy on you I don't know I've been going
very easy on you you're pretty tough on
me oh I've been going very easy on you
give them to me maybe whoa dude Giuliani
is so vile this is like you know I want
to clean my tits this is like 50 Shades
of Gray except instead of a hot
businessman it's like the Penguin from
Batman it's like I have a rule that no
matter what uh if you if you're like
sexting or if you're like doing sex talk
if you transcribe it it's always going
to look bad but this is like
it's like additionally bad it's it's bad
across the board there's no way that you
can salvage that you could have like
the sexiest man on the planet you could
have like a like a a a sequence where
like Jason Momoa is what what are you
pulling up Ethan what okay listen I have
a you guys sent me the most complicated
[__] lunch menu to order from I can't
order for you you sent me a tiny picture
that I can't even read can we order from
someone with a menu dude please we're
just gonna order for you look at this
venue they sent me to to do what during
the show I'm sorry Hassan they want me
to do step one two three
Choose Or mix and match choose just
scroll down scroll down there it is
these are set you told me there's a
[__] they can become how am I
supposed to read this tiny text they can
become raps it says yeah it's a salad a
wrap under each option
dude have you ever seen smaller texts
and I have good eyes okay give me a
break please
thank you and I tried to open it because
it's so small I can't see and then open
on the [__] screen is hey sorry right
now sorry it's okay go ahead
um
Jesus
all right well
um getting back to Mr Giuliani uh sex
talking uh uh his his uh associate here
he says you are my [__] and then miss
Dunford responds indiscernible [__] Mr
Juliana responds you're my [__] you're
my [__] [__] Jesus God you make me
feel better when I'm upset I hope I make
you feel better when you're upset Miss
Dunphy says you do to which Mr Giuliani
replies indiscernible so smart so much
potential this tremendous attraction to
you physically I can't think about you
or I get hard even even if I think about
how smart you are I'll get hard I'd
never think about a girl being smart if
you told me a girl was smart I would
often think she's not attractive
misogynistic Grizz
uh yeah it's hard to I don't know that
people have talked like this even if you
were like an astronaut I could see you
in a being like a female astronaut
normally that would turn me off but with
you
um that still makes my dick hard
I think we had read this one before
there was like yeah excerpts of some of
these that had been leaked and yeah that
we had read previously but come over
here big tits is pretty that's a Vibe
right yeah but get over here I want to
clean my tits get over you bring those
it's the repeating at four times
like he's just like a [__] Gremlin
it's also the fact that these are audio
transcripts for me that that seals the
deal that like I need to hear them I
need to hear him say these things bro
that would be the greatest thing ever
as you can see in the transcripts uh
regardless of like the element of
coercion given the boss assistant uh
work structure that he is totally valid
for doing this or whatever because like
she was asking for it she thought your
honor she thought I was so sexy what
about the Jews one
um that stuff is not illegal no it's not
illegal it's just funny no oh no it's
everything
lawsuit I don't think anyone's trying to
lock them up for this are they no no I I
was just saying like uh
I'm just uh trying to figure out how he
would craft a defense against this right
not saying that it's valid obviously I
don't think so
well I think Rudy's about to be ruined
because he got indicted in this new one
which we should talk about now and if
anyone gets thrown under the bus and the
one person I can guarantee everybody
hates is Rudy Giuliani yeah Sydney
Powell is not well liked as well we're
talking now we've moved on to the most
indicted man in America yeah yeah yeah
okay good and just to clarify Rudy is
not all the co-conspirators have not yet
been indicted they might be he's been
named he's been yeah well he's part of
it but he's part of the sixth so the
gang of six six and so Trump is up to 78
charges this year God damn he's racking
him up he is the goat dude he is so sick
although I was listening to the to the
news this morning
I think it was like uh 40 of all
Republicans think Trump did nothing
wrong yeah they don't acknowledge no any
of this out of Trump's out of Trump's
base or sorry not forty percent it's
like yeah support
polling was conducted by the New York
Times I think that's what you're talking
about right yeah um okay
this part is insane I often have this
meme on my stream where I say you can
get 30 of Americans that agree on
anything no matter how [__] insane it
is it's the 30 principle for America
okay they believe angels are real all
this crazy stuff right
out of the base of support for Donald
Trump the hardcore Maga hardliners
zero people think he's done anything
illegal yeah zero I'm not saying one not
one person five percent not two people
not ten people zero zero of Trump's Maga
base of support which makes up thirty
percent of the the basis part of the
Republican Party say he has done
anything wrong I think the 40 million
percent was from so like 30 percent or
no it's more than that it's 43 I think
this isn't just Maga this is all
Republicans all Republicans like 60 or I
think think he did nothing 74 say uh
he's done nothing wrong uh only 13 say
he has committed serious crime and uh
it looks like another 13 or so they they
just don't know
there's like a really Slim margin of
people I believe in like his base right
now like his base of support not just
the entire Republican party that was
pulled that said I think it was like two
percent or three percent or something
that said
yeah he might have done something wrong
but it's okay we don't mind
um but that's why we like him it's
[__] awesome okay but the more you
look at this and the more you look at
like Ron DeSantis the more you come to
the realization that like yeah no it's
just Charisma like they love him he's a
TV man and that's it he owns the libs
and that's it you know but that the fact
that this is the third one and arguably
the worst one by far so far of the three
I feel like people are getting fatigued
you know I agree it's like indictment
indictment who's got an indictment Go
Fish it's like a you know I don't know
because and so by now especially when
he's done everything right right yeah
which he has yeah and so by now anyone
who was like oh these who might be
skeptical of of what Trump's done is
gonna start being like this is just a
circus this is obviously just a
political hit job it's hard for them to
understand that he really is that big of
a piece of [__] and criminal but at any
rate I just don't know if all these
indictments are going to
[Music]
um
have a lessened effect because there's
just been so [__] many of them now
you know and I'm not saying that
um they shouldn't be bringing it because
nobody's above the law but what I am
saying is
I don't know I don't think this third
one is going to be very impactful even
though it's the worst
Trump is the new Nelson Mandela in what
way is that Joey you want to impact that
and the fact that he's about to go to
jail for 30 years
excited yeah I mean yeah similar for
similar reasons you know what I mean
they're Trump is also uh fighting
against a brutal apartheid regime in
America yeah the real apartheid which is
uh jet ski dealership owners uh against
the rest of the country yep against the
whites man it's not yeah
so okay let's take a look uh here's
special counsel Jack Smith holding a
fake name right Jack Smith Dan is
doubtful of that I think it's a false
identity where he's laying out the
charges and by the way can I say that
this man looks like Adam 22.
does anyone else see it oh my God kind
of oh we're also disrespecting Jack
Smith right now okay respect I don't
want to back on him maybe Jack Smith is
just an alias of Adam 22.
name well we got it what's that the uh
that dude who [__] Adam's wife
Jason love we gotta get Jason love to
come pound his wife his wife is a
documentarian made a documentary about
Michelle Obama oh yeah oh bias bias get
him out of here yeah that's true that's
it wow yeah he was Prosecuting Warcraft
uh war criminals in The Hague so
so at any rate here is Jack Smith if
that is your real name
good evening
today an indictment was unsealed
charging Donald J Trump with conspiring
to defraud the United States
conspiring to disenfranchise voters
and conspiring and attempting to
obstruct an official proceeding
the indictment was issued by a Grandeur
of citizens here in the District of
Columbia
and it sets forth the crimes charged in
detail
I encourage everyone to read it in full
the attack on our nation's capital on
January 6 2021
was an unprecedented assault on the seat
of American democracy
it's described in the indictment it was
fueled by lies
Lies by the defendant targeted at
obstructing a Bedrock function of the
U.S government
the nation's process of collecting
counting and certifying the results of
the presidential election
the men and women of law enforcement who
defended the U.S Capitol on January 6
are heroes
they are Patriots and they are the very
best of us
they did not just defend a building or
the people Sheltering in it got some
Chatters Thursdays
I think he's an attractive guy he's
projecting like uh they defended the
very instant power principles
stabilities this is definitely he has
the vibe of somebody you don't want to
get prosecuted yeah I know I mean like
he's like the main the archetypal like
oh you're [__] yeah he looks like he
looks like one of those like OG Mormon
uh G-Men you know what I mean where he's
just like he doesn't drink and he's like
very very strict and very ridiculous
about all of the day-to-date he gathers
like he definitely has that aesthetic to
him yeah the first thing I thought when
I saw him was like this guy's got to be
scared shitless because there's going to
be so many psychos
you know his ass is running marathons
too like he's like that type of dude in
the dome like Nancy's husband
oh you know you think he'll no he'll
he'll bust some ass okay also he lives
in the Netherlands what are they going
to do he does uh yeah they can't get
them there usually well not right now
probably for them because it's like
security though because there are some
real freaks out there yeah I imagine as
well as the many career prosecutors and
law enforcement agents
shout out to jacket off Smith
for uh
doing something really Brave and really
difficult he's pretty he's pretty matter
of fact about it
um so I've been thinking a lot about
this about my main man Donald Trump
getting indicted so many times despite
doing everything right
and um you know obviously the Deep State
pedophiles are coming after him right
you know because they're jealous of his
power yeah um
But ultimately
you're right I do think that there is a
lot of fatigue around this I do think
that it's not as entertaining the first
time it was like whoa that's crazy like
we kind of blew a load of us are loving
it but people who could be potentially
persuaded by this are over it I think
yeah I feel like it's just contributing
to a depressive uh it's depressing voter
turnout and it's going to uh contribute
to having like
probably very low voter turnout in
general in 2024 you're saying yeah
unless they unless they uh keep some of
the uh mail-in ballot initiatives from
covid which Republicans have been
actively trying to undermine which
genuinely makes it easier for people to
vote uh unless they do that it's most
likely going to have uh a chilling
effect it's most likely going to uh uh
cause people to not vote because you're
just like ugh I don't care like [__]
Trump yeah Joe Biden is old yeah nothing
is like uh you know there's there's
nothing here for me
the question is does it does press turn
out for Trump more than it does for Joe
press depressed depressed like who do
you think is more like
worn out on politics by all of this like
Trump space I think it's the Democrat I
think it's the moderate Republicans
right who are like potentially swayable
but they're gonna be like this is just a
joke they're like they'll just stay home
they won't vote for Biden they might not
vote or they'll or they'll vote for
Trump because they think that he's it's
a hit job on him right by the way these
are the charges of the new um
indictment it's just when I look at Fox
news coverage of this stuff it is like
understandable why the Trump base is
just seemingly on a different planet
yeah so the way they the way they cover
it is just so absolutely nutty I I just
like this is like Nazi Germany
government takeover prosecute you know
going after our legal opponent or
our our uh political opponents yeah
and Stalin the worst part about it I
mean I guess it's not the worst part
about it but like the one funny uh issue
here is that like they [__] know they
know right they know they know from like
League documents yeah they know they
just very openly and very deliberately
lying to their audience over and over
and over again so that they can
brainwash them into uh being servile
little Hogs that will go out and vote
but ultimately I think there is a a a a
ironic situation here with like
why you should vote for Trump now it's
basically turning into like vote red no
matter who like you know how Democrats
have the vote blue no matter who uh
initiative that have they they Implement
every election cycle this is the most
important election of our lifetimes this
is the most important election of our
lifetimes like I'm seeing a lot of
Republicans do that as well now rather
than vote for something owning the libs
or I don't know Banning abortion or
whatever the [__] they're like no no you
gotta you gotta Vote or else they'll
throw Trump in jail
do you think this is the most important
election of our lifetime no no I don't
no I don't I I think all elections are
important in in a similar capacity but
ultimately I think the American
government is on autopilot and it's like
either marginally going to be worse
and the lever is going to be cranked in
One Direction only to have Democrats
seize control of all facets of
government and never crank it in the
other direction or it's just going to
keep going uh more and more right wing
yeah I wonder what's the worst thing
Trump could do in office I mean George
Bush kind of out outdid him by a lot
yeah well yeah he's like yo I don't
think people really understand what a
murderous [__] genocidal freak he was
his of his administration his
administration yeah I feel like a
million civilians yeah yep that's like
one of the big genocides of of of of of
human history it and it has largely been
memory hold it's pretty wild
suddenly
people will get that's a controversial
take you know that right what's wrong
about it liberals would get mad at you
for saying a lot of liberal yeah I mean
a lot of people think Trump's like the
worst president ever yeah wait wait wait
what about what is that is is everything
that you said is objectively and
demonstrably correct so but why would
they be mad about that statement um
because recency bias and also orange man
bad they're mad that I'm not saying
Trump is the worst president of all time
oh and also and frankly because I think
he is horrible a lot of a lot of
liberals
supported the Iraq War you know what I
mean yeah post 911 uh liberalism they
were lied to by George Bush yeah they
were lied he was like there's a nuke you
didn't have to take the bait they were
they were lied to 9 11 is like a massive
scar for the American psyche that like
genuinely changed uh the way that back
in the day there used to be at least
like you know anti-war liberalism that's
gone like doesn't exist
doesn't exist whatsoever I'm not super
CR listen I understand that liberals who
voted for it
because
that's great if you did it and I think
that's an incredible badge of honor but
when some when the administration's like
we have evidence that they have nuclear
bombs
and then you go there and they're like
as actually the thing is they don't
really understand contemporaneously
there were people pointing out the flaws
in all of this yeah and they just didn't
listen yeah I mean because there were
Democrats that voted no yeah that not
all Democrats went for it but for
example Joe Biden voted for the Iraq War
yeah which I don't know the fact that
that's not just like automatically
disqualifying it's interesting because
it's crazy to me it's interesting
because it was though
Barack Obama
hammered Hillary Clinton right in 2008
for her decisions
but then Barack Obama for eight years uh
with all of his charisma
basically continued
the exact same war on terror [__] he
ran on closing Guantanamo Bay he did not
do that he actually he made an increase
serious state yeah that is funny that is
yeah he then also increased uh troops in
the surge uh and hey lady who I'm uh
accusing of war crimes you want to be in
charge of our foreign policy yeah yeah
it's so you know that's
and [__] too and then after that I
think after that liberals completely
tapped out of like ever being
contentious towards War they just are
now
you know they they eat State Department
propaganda Hook Line and Sinker there's
no there's no critique there's no
there's not really any in the Trump
years there was a little bit because but
it it was more just the reflexive
whatever Trump's doing is bad yeah like
any kind of critical absolutely but
Liberals are very reactionary in that
sort I mean regard there people forget
there's been some really terrible
presidents like what was this guy he's
widely held to be the worst it's um
uh there was this one guy who was like
what's this [__] name I'm trying to
find out
was it Harding
Harding is considered a pretty awful one
like some of these dudes literally did
[__] nothing but like drink and give
contracts to their friends and I was not
that different than Trump frankly yeah I
was about to say it's not as different
than than most modern most contemporary
presidents the only difference is like
liberals at least abide by civility
standards to a certain degree like
Democrats do it in a professional manner
but some and Republicans usually do it
in a professional manner as well where
Trump was very Brazen with his
corruption and very open about it and he
was like yeah what are you gonna do
about it like this is how the system is
this is how it's supposed to be I'm not
doing anything weird or was it Hoover I
don't know there's a lot of shitty
presidents Hoover was President uh uh
what do you call it around the time
leading up to the Great Depression a lot
of people point to him for that kind of
stuff he's the man but generally most of
the worst Presidents are generally
considered to be the like three or four
that led up to the Civil War which it's
kind of hard to argue against that
seeing as what the outcome of their
Administration you might say they
dropped the ball they dropped the ball a
little bit yeah
yeah so let's see here's the charges
against Trump uh conspiracy to defraud
the United States conspiracy to impede
the January 6 Congressional proceeding
conspiracy against the right to vote and
to have that vote counted obstruction of
an attempt to obstruct and impede the
certificate the certification of the
electoral vote
that's there it is and there are charges
so that'll be fun to see but yeah I
don't know what's going to be the
outcome of this I mean I really don't
you know
there's just too much apathy or or
frankly disbelief paranoia propaganda I
don't know
I do you think that he's gonna get
convicted
because honestly I have a different
conversation once that starts happening
like the I agree like the indictments
it's like people are worn out on because
it's like yeah yeah he's arrested again
nothing nothing's happened but you know
if he
gets found guilty I don't know that
these people will change their mind I
think I changed mine but I think it will
be more of what Hassan was saying of
just like
depressing uh you know what I mean just
just yeah just disheartening them to the
extent that they just don't even bother
what will he get will he get arrested I
have no idea I genuinely don't but he's
not wrestling behind you convicted in
prison
it was like a crazy amount of years
right yeah this one specifically is like
50 years 40 years something
let's see
Pence by the way has flipped on his on
his boy yeah snake uh he came out I know
uh he's he's
out here just showing his his ass dude
it's really [__] up it's really messed
up man he dropped this tweet that was
it's really messed up I don't even want
to see it I can't even look at this out
I'm gonna read it when he got served
Mike Pence said this today's indictment
serves an important reminder Anyone who
puts himself over the Constitution never
be president United States [__] where
were you
he was there wearing a wired yeah it's
so [__] up dude dude this is po we're
living in a post gonna world okay
it's just dogs snitching on dogs turning
into rats you know what I'm saying it's
a [__] dog eat dog world out there
like ask your boys to be fair Trump what
did want him hangs it by The Gallows
yeah it turns out he was right
it turns out he was like
he was not wrong for that uh that
feeling
of anger uh it's like I'm surprised
Trump doesn't tweet out this picture
when he put out that statement we're
coming for you Mikey boy yeah Mikey it's
so funny because like you know Mike
Pence is saying all this stuff and he's
just his poll numbers are so disastrous
which to me implies that there is
no interest within the Republican base
to for anyone to say
uh truthful things about Donald Trump's
uh misconduct criminal conduct but Mike
is also like the most uncharismatic
pasty weirdo to Fair
um and also the dude literally he tried
to run he announced his president's uh
candidacy he raised 1.2 million dollars
twitch streamers get more donations than
him yeah I've raised more money for you
yeah Syria and Turkish uh earthquake
relief funds then then Michael Pence's
VP run
in a matter of like a week too
so let's see Pence's handwritten notes
and testimony played a crucial role
during the indictment
that's very interesting
um these notes were taken by pence in
the days between 2020 election the
January 6 attack on the capital so a
prolific Note Taker apparently they
describe private interaction with Trump
and are believed to have been used by
prosecutors in drawing up the charges
against drum okay Pence
there it is
Stringer Bell would be pissed [__] is
you take
foreign
the wire if you haven't seen it
definitely watch it [__] is you taking
notes on a criminal [__] conspiracy
that's true that's a good point that
show's so good
but notes are useful
so we don't forget do you think he was
doing it knowing yes like he was
covering his ass big time oh yeah yeah
he knew that [__] was gonna go sideways
sooner or later their their counter now
his lawyer has been making the rounds
Trump's lawyers been making the rounds
on CNN yeah they have a new guy he's
like more coherent than uh Joey Taco
penis or Matthew calamari or all of the
other wonderful characters and themed
lawyers that he has yeah
um well one of the one of the guys one
of the co-conspirators uh named in the
in the suit is uh Kenneth cheese bro oh
yeah I saw that where the [__] is he
finding these people is it chess bro or
is it I mean it's spelled like cheese uh
it's c h uh e s e v r o
it's like probably Chessa bro maybe I
don't know but no I thought I thought it
was c-h-e-e-s-e no I don't think he's I
don't think no it's not I just looked up
yeah
bro it looks like cheese bro though it
does look like chicken bro which I will
continue calling him that so what about
our food themed uh players
it's just I don't know I don't know
where Trump finds these [__] freaks
but it's like very obvious that in every
single circumstance that he has been uh
in every indictment so far
here's how it plays out
a normal lawyer tells Donald Trump sir
you can't do that that is illegal
whether it be uh maintaining classified
documents uh after an investigation has
launched into uh taking those classified
documents back okay someone will say sir
you can't do that that's illegal
cooperate with the authorities and give
the documents back Trump will then
completely avoid that and go and find
any legal counsel he can that will tell
him no actually sir you're perfectly
fine that's where he finds the freaks
yeah so he went to Judicial Watch which
is uh Tom fitton's operation for the
classified document stuff where Tom
fitton was like oh yeah totally just
keep the documents lie to them who gives
a [__] right
and then he will and then in this
situation the exact same thing happened
where they were like sir the election
was not stolen you know that that's not
the case like he has uh legal counsel
that told him this he had professionals
within his administration that his job
is solely this to inform him on matters
such as this tell him no what you're
saying is false so he reasonably knew
the information that he was delivering
to the public uh it with an intent to
defraud the the population was
completely false the amount he found
freaks that's you're you're right the
amount of people that told him that the
election wasn't stolen that it was fair
that he's wrong it was like 10 to 15
credible office holders or lawyers or
judges or I don't know his own people
his own people and so it's that's all
that's one of the most damning evidences
they have of intent because they're like
there's no [__] way that this man did
not know that he was lying well let's
should we talk about the clear five-part
plan on how to steal the election
because the indictment lays it out
um
so one
knowingly making false claims of
election fraud to get state legislators
and election officials to subvert the
legitimate election results
um on the pretext of baseless fraud
claims Trump pushed officials in certain
states to ignore the popular vote
disenfranchise millions of Voters
dismiss legitimate electors and
ultimately cause the ascertainment of
voting by illegitimate electors in favor
of the defendant this is per the
indictment I don't see anything wrong
with that yeah no he did nothing wrong
yeah two
organizing a fraudulent slate of
electors in seven targeted states which
include Arizona Georgia Michigan Nevada
New Mexico Pennsylvania and Wisconsin
Michigan there's a new lawsuit some
fraudulent electors were tricked into
participating based on the understanding
that their votes would be used only if
the defendant succeeded in outcome
determinative lawsuits within their
state we should defend it never did oops
number three three trying to use the
power of the Department of Justice to
conduct sham election crime
investigations which to be fair
number three has been happening
under every Republican Administration
George W bush did it uh there is always
a committee Donald Trump did it in 2016.
he tried to do it again after he lost
that's the only difference is that he
actually lost this time
um but uh he has like well I guess they
don't use the Department of Justice but
they usually always will create a
separate
team to to and they'll call it like the
election Integrity office or whatever
which will go and like do uh analyzes on
all of the votes and and try to tabulate
all the fraudulent votes or whatever
only to find the exact same conclusion
every election cycle there is not enough
voter fraud happening yeah there's not
enough voter fraud happening
uh that is beyond the margins there's
not enough voter fraud happening at a
systemic level that like legitimately
changes the outcome uh of an election
it's a complete erroneous claim and then
to which Trump or even Georgia Bush will
quietly then just shudder the election
Integrity committee and move on and
never talk about it again
um but this time he utilize the doj the
indictment alleges that Trump and
co-conspirators sent a letter to the
targeted states that falsely claimed
that the justice department had
identified significant concerns that may
have impacted their election outcome
can you do that no barely not no because
Trump wrote a letter
two states
that says the justice department the
official legal uh wing of the of the
executive branch they had identified
uh significant because so they're just
like yo this [__] was stolen trust all
while the the irony Bill bar thing like
why isn't he in trouble
um oh he just lied Trump bar wasn't
involved yeah all while awesome all the
while they were launching investigations
and lawsuits over and over again
and every single one of them was either
being thrown out
or failing like it's not like there
wasn't subsequent recounts that occurred
multiple times in a lot of these states
that were Trump alleged that there was
uh some misconduct on on uh voting um
so they did actually tabulate the
results count them over and over again
hand count them this was an incredibly
costly Endeavor it cost Millions
multiple tens of millions of dollars did
this campaign pay for the recounts um I
believe that you're supposed to yes is
probably some Pax uh Pac money you know
it's not directly coming out of Trump's
pocket or anything
um
then last uh well the last two points he
tried to get former vice president
Michael Pence to fraudulently alter the
election results so what ended up
happening was he basically pulled Mike
Pence aside and was like
come on my boy come on this this like my
legal counsel is telling me
this is it January 6th don't authorize
the vote results let's let's let's stop
this you know let's let's put a pin in
this whole election thing long after the
election is over mind you long after
Americans are completely aware that like
Joe Biden is the next president of the
United States is the lame duck period
that he has where he doesn't have any
like uh I mean he has power obviously
and can be use it but like everyone is
under the assumption the correct
assumption that like Joe Biden is the
next president of the United States of
America there just has to be a transfer
of power at this point
so what did Trump try to do well he
tried to convince when efforts of
convince Pence to unilaterally reject
election results before January 6 failed
Trump and co-conspirators falsely told
protesters that Pence had the authority
to and might alter the election results
that's that's really incredible because
they're like he's basically pressuring
pence from his psycho fans yeah that's
why they took out the gala from that boy
yep Trump and co-conspirators directed
them to the Capitol to obstruct the
certification proceeding and exert
pressure on the vice president to take
the fraudulent actions he had previously
refused Mike Pence very clearly defined
and you can see it in the I mean he even
talked about it publicly recently since
this indictment came out but
um
he he very clearly told Trump like I
don't believe I have the power to do
that nor do I wish to
uh to do that like in in correspondences
that was documented
and last but not least exploiting
January 6 violence to get members of
Congress to delay certification is
violence ensued the defendant and
co-conspirators exploited the disruption
by redoubling efforts to Levy false
claims of election fraud and convince
members of Congress to further delay the
certification based on those claims now
Mike Pence the key witness here uh for
that uh reason we we touched on what he
said uh another thing that actually I
thought was interesting is one of the
co-conspirators
uh I I think said something along the
lines of like uh well there will be
riots if we actually stop this uh
authorization process because everybody
knows that you know Joe Biden is the
next president if you if you think you
can like symbolically stop this process
like and halt it like people will riot
to which uh a co-conspirator responded
well that's why we have the Insurrection
act like he wanted to use the military
the understandable riots that would
ensue due to the the Democratic process
being halted on like one of the more
symbolic uh aspects of it too I mean
it's serious it's a good thing that
Pence even though he is a pasty ghoulish
zombie-ish freak that he did not do this
because that would have been really
[__] crazy yeah he has handwritten
notes and testimony that played a
crucial role in the indictment against
Donald Trump these contemporary
contemporaneous notes were taken by
pence in the days between the 2020
election and the January 6 attack on the
capitol they describe private
interactions with Trump and are believed
to have been used by prosecutors in
drawing up the charges against Trump
oops Yeah
um he he took notes and you know as we
know Trump hates notes Trump hates
people that take notes for good reason
because he's like constantly saying [__]
that would get hit once again from a
criminal [__] conspiracy to anyone in
a room with him at any time yeah but
that's the thing it wasn't just Pence
there's so much of the [__] that they
put in writing for like no reason well
it's not no reason you're the president
every conversation that you're supposed
to be having in private or in public
should at least to certain degree
regardless of classification be
diligently uh uh you know safeguarded
and and diligently taken notes on that's
normal he the problem is
he's not he's never operated like this
he's always failed upwards in the real
estate world where he could be a
criminal as much as he wants to and and
run the show in the way that he wants to
but like when you're the [__]
president you can't do that like you
just can't get away with that
let's see one of the conversations
documented in Pence knows took place on
Christmas Day 2020. Pence called Trump
to deliver a holiday greeting how sweet
but the then president quickly turned
the conversation to his demand that
Pence reject certain State electoral
votes during the final certification
he's like hey Merry Christmas Trump
listen
save the merry Christmas for after
Pence reportedly pushed back telling
Trump you know I don't think I have the
authority to change the outcome
what the vice president can't change the
outcome of an election
another conversation took place on New
Year's Day 2021 oh the holidays I think
that's the only time they ever talked I
love just thinking about how Pence
was probably sighing and like okay I got
a call I gotta call trumpy I gotta call
Donald they only talked on these
holidays Happy New Year right now and I
know how this is going to go so let's
see he calls him a New Year's Day five
days before the capital attack Trump
allegedly called Pence to berate him
about opposing a lawsuit filed by
Trump's allies aiming to have a Judicial
opinion stating that Pence had the
authority
Trump was demanding of him okay wait
wait
Trump
was trying to get a legal opinion that
said that yeah I don't think he got that
right I don't think so well you can get
a legal opinion on whatever the [__] you
want to get a legal opinion on it's just
it's not a it's a matter of whether it's
uh valid or not and uh it's a matter of
like
are we going to wait out the litigation
or are we just going to follow through
on this again symbolic part of the
electoral process like elections process
like this isn't a pivotal moment the the
certification of votes is not like uh
is not necessarily an important part of
the process within the elections they
didn't
cheat hard enough in the beginning which
is where Republicans do actually shine
where they engage in systemic uh I would
say criminal misconduct with respect to
voter suppression because individual
voter fraud does not happen in this
country in a meaningful way however
election fraud is a constant and
Republicans in order to justify that
election fraud claim voter fraud is
happening they say voter fraud is
happening even though there's no
evidence to point to it and there's
never been evidence to point to this
okay I don't know if you've seen those
tapes the the there was a guy with a box
yeah I mean exactly exactly and they
investigate it and they're like no
you're an idiot that's not a real thing
right
um however
they claim that it's happening
regardless to say you know illegal
immigrants are voting blah blah blah so
that they can justify election fraud so
they can engineer outcomes uh to ensure
that like certain areas uh uh don't have
an easy time voting black and brown
neighborhoods poor neighborhoods
neighborhoods that would vote Democrat
in general are often uh riddled with uh
a or often hit with like a bunch of uh a
bunch of different hurdles to make it as
difficult as possible to vote
I mean the very fact that elections are
not conducted on a Federal holiday in
and of itself that is you're right is is
crazy I mean it's deliberate it's a
deliberate attempt to make working-class
people not vote because they don't want
you to vote yeah it's pretty sad uh
here's a good moment from New Year's Day
um
I have to pee while you uh after Pence
told Trump once more that there was no
basis for him to ever claim or wield
that sort of authority Trump complained
that Pence was too honest you're too
honest you're too honest kid you're too
honest here's a Gallow make you a little
less honest you understand
uh let's see Pence is on video now uh oh
I mean he's the whitest [__]
that ever lived look at this dude
look at this white [__] it's
Angelic I agree
look at him what's his background like
what's his ethnicity I wonder it's got
to be like
uh wasp as [__] I would guess you know
what I mean where where what country's
putting out people this white England
Ireland uh Ireland uh yeah probably
you know what I mean like this is this
is a special breed
when we're
his father was German okay that's a good
that's a good uh there you go good stuff
there it is man Irish and German let's
keep that white white stock baby
no Spice in that stock just water we
know how to make food delicious really
white that's right broken and written
about it extensively like I have nothing
to help
look at me I'm out here with the
tractors
I'm out here at Tractor con 2023
and I'll tell you what man I'm the
whitest person you ain't ever seen
vote for me
you ever seen me on a tractor big old
John Deere
tell you what brother Yeehaw I know how
to mount my way around one of them
that's Grace uh I believe we did our
duty that day look at these just like
people cruising around look at that dude
I mean this guy is not good at walking
he's got overall he has a straw hat damn
this is where this is where good old the
real America congregate that's the real
America
that's right we've dropped we don't even
walk no more we just rock crews around
the golf carts bro
the Constitution look at that guy man
that's America
that is America that's Old MacDonald
right there boy
shirts on that he's coming back oh yeah
Dan wants to hear this we uh Mike Pence
is giving a speech down at the fact uh
The Tractor Yard
with a good old boy in the back
got a wheat stick in his mouth black
speaking to the Constitution a corn cop
pipe and to the American people the
Constitution is quite clear about the
role of the Vice President in the
counting of electoral votes it
essentially says the vice president
presides over a joint session of
Congress where the electoral votes that
are certified by the streets
shall be open and shall be accountable
preach and irrespective of the
indictment I want the American people to
know that I had no right to overturn the
election
Casper the Friendly Ghost looking ass I
think he looks like an angel no rizz
whatsoever though he's glowing he's so
white the sun gives him the illusion of
a of a Halo frankly Dan like an angel
yeah
president Trump asked me to put him over
the Constitution that I chose the
Constitution That's my boy that's my boy
and I I uh I really do believe that uh
Anyone who puts himself over the
Constitution should never be president
of the United States that's right and
anyone who asks someone else to put
themselves over the Constitution should
never be president of the United States
that's right
I've been very forthright about this
issue and I'll continue this is too long
I mean what the [__] oh
pants
I hate to say it brother but you're done
your time has run low you don't cross
Trump now boy you best be looking out
one of them tractors there bound to go
off-road
it ain't just be cutting grass you're
not wrong Mitch McConnell also crossed
them think about it
Mitch McConnell is a rhino he's fake he
crossed Trump and then you know uh I
look at him yeah the tall the death
tolls are coming for him I'm telling you
my pants you done made a deal with the
dip it is really wild to me that like
Mike Pence
his starting point is actually
you know having a radio show is that
right yeah no no yeah like he was just
like he was he would just like say
unhinged stuff though and he had to be
somewhat charismatic to be able to have
there's no shot this man had his
Charisma can we get a clip of him on the
radio I think we found one once we
digged it up and it was very just bog
standard Midwest I woke up this morning
and mama called me
Mama made me eggs and eggs and bacon I
said mama you know I don't eat bacon I'm
just I maintain the position that you
have to be at least somewhat
entertaining uh you know over a long
period of time to be able to to make it
at least in a way that uh works with
your audience
so it's uh actually shocking that he's
so bad wait I gotta see this that's him
that's got to be someone yeah from the
90s what he looks so different he was
all different women in the military and
by the middle of the week though we're
talking about not only being full screen
of the Air Force and the need for
discipline but also
um the whole National debate about
adultery and we had Cal Thomas's column
on Wednesday in many Hoosier newspapers
that reflected on this business of the
normalization he's born again but that
case in fact have you ever heard about
it what the [__] he looks so different
in the case of the Air Force versus
almost 30 years ago he agreed to resign
yesterday in general
dischargeable
criminal charges on adultery and it's
like a dance
other charges now so you get the vibe
right I mean you want more yeah I don't
I don't know if his care is a matter a
general discharge he's talking about
adultery and [__]
guys
yeah I mean definitely not there's
probably crushes in Indiana
punishment but it doesn't prevent access
to Veterans Benefits you've also got
below that an undesirable discharge a
bad conduct discharge and a dishonorable
discharge so the first question I have
for you at 800-603
6453 was was just as served anybody
remembering that number I mean getting
the getting a discharge all right I mean
just a whisper thank
you you get the vibe
do you hear that
um
the Bell right yeah the bell's coming
for him my past you done flew too close
to the Sun boy
now you hang it around like you one of
us at The Tractor Yard boy
that's gonna be your last mistake
brother
I tell you what man you ain't got no
secret service no more
maybe we shouldn't joke about this
because
there's a non-zero chance that one a
trump reporter actually does try and uh
yeah and you don't want to get you don't
want to get like oh this is my age you
know why they called the Secret Service
boy
because they in a secret doing service
for somebody else you understand
the Patriots are rising up sounds can
you hit could you have Pro Sounds Zach
to play at the same time uh I can try
and do that yeah
go ahead sorry Hassan no I'm just saying
Patriots are rising up the Patriots are
in control
uh Michael Pence's crimes against the uh
the Trump administration at the behest
of deep State pedophiles the demon rats
uh-huh
coming for you Michael I mean they're
not even I I feel like uh they're coming
for him in the in the way that uh he's
getting
he's getting no support and no love
whatsoever
you hear that why
they gonna Feast on your bones Michael
them scarecrows ain't gonna stop them
because them crows is smart and they
know what flesh tastes good and we're
just don't
and your flesh bar
it's gonna taste good
to them crows
all right okay this is why I
unironically believe we could do better
as like right-wing commentators than the
current right-wing commentators like not
not a single one of them has like the
same Pizzazz or interest in like doing
some kind of quick theater Stephen
Crowder No all he does is just like
dress up as a woman because that's his
own personal hobby that he wants oh
speaking of which I wanted to show this
to you he used a clip from our show to
promote uh Club leftovers he clipped it
he used a clip of Dan but not me
Crowder might be dead like this video
has a hundred thousand views after two
days
you shall be referred to as Stephen
kawada
extremely misogynistic and sexist he's
also homophobic he's a disgusting
garbage human being who's been his brand
from the very beginning just go look at
the titles of that guy's videos like
he's like the king of like saying
horrible offenses dude twice yep God
damn I know you're you're naughty
they got you because you're bald let's
be real
but no for real let's check I got snipe
yeah let's check his numbers I mean [__]
uh here's another special announcement
50 000 Chill on the Mud Club ship bro I
know you're desperate damn uh what's
this social blade looking like the death
tolls are coming for Crowder even though
he's been on Trump's side it seems
uh yeah they've been on another Hiatus
since his latest controversy
um which I'm sure well it's a total
coincidence here look at two weeks ago
this is an hour-long episode 106 000.
he's trying to he's probably trying to
plug all the leaks in his ship at the
moment you know I think he's like when
you got mediaite breaking stories about
how you love showing your [__] to your
co-workers yeah people that you've hired
you know it's not it's not a good look
the family value I mean and yeah the I
think even his conservative fans are
going to be a little bit moved by the
fact that well it's because it's like
this way like that's I think yeah
they're like oh he's doing some gay [__]
I don't really understand it what the
[__] that about what do we see here
minus ten thousand he's losing Subs join
the club [__] me and you Doug now we're
out of the hole now here what do you
mean we've been out of the hole but I'm
not I'm not celebrating yet okay I'll be
out of the hole for a little bit longer
yeah yeah I'm still in the hall still in
the hole Rat Hole I'm still in the Rat
Hole so let's see how he's doing on
Rumble because I remember he had like a
gajillion so according to rumble this
same episode got
760 000 views I I damn I'm a B plus I I
I'm losing am I losing Subs what your B
plus I'm gonna be on you baby uh Social
Security yeah crowd was only a b yeah
let's go Steven
um I have no way to prove it and could
be totally wrong but I I just don't
think the numbers on Rumble are real I
agree I think they just artificially
inflate you don't say there's no no that
people are going from YouTube to this
weird random platform and getting more
numbers it's just not possible no way I
know how the internet works man the guys
don't these guys would surely never
bought the [__] out of their websites I
mean come on look how many people are on
this website right now you don't even
mean like botting I just mean like
Rumble is just like manually
I agree give two views for every one or
something their podcasts are crushing 10
000 views right now let's take a look
uh in the litter box click on it and
then look at the chat
okay all right and maybe take it off we
might immediately this is in the litter
box
let's see what we got how many people
are watching four thousand people are
watching chat is incredibly slow
should I that's interesting there hasn't
been an n-word yet okay maybe it's okay
I just didn't want to you know get
ourselves in trouble here Obama and
Biden are both worthy of hating okay
they sold out our country damn it ditch
Mitch these people are just Bots man
it's crazy Only God Can Deliver Us from
this evil these are actual comments
happening right now
only God can deliver us I don't feel
sorry for Hunter it's a sar report
undertook money connected to human
trafficking
they should go bungee jump without this
you know what this this reads like um
I mean do they have like slow mode on or
something because if it's not if there's
no restriction on it yeah and it reads
like uh like a 200 300 person chat the
the speed of which uh the chat is moving
right and the interactions that are
coming
this country is done
anyway yeah whatever rumbles really
good place man you're gonna do great
there Steve right side broadcasting the
indictment of President Donald Trump 56k
views let's take a look at that one oh
really hey go up is it the top
so right side broadcasting is one of the
major contributors uh with a seditious
conspiracy for January 6. this is
Marjorie Taylor Green's boyfriend right
is that really him yeah in the January 6
uh look at that chat for 56k views Seven
Seals that's 50 where how many viewers
is this it says it says 27 000. wait why
did it say 56 in the beginning am I
black too no it did say a pawn right
here it says 20. I know it was I mean
Let me refresh we have 31k look at our
chat in comparison to their chat and
ours is on sub only yeah
oh right good point do they have to go
faster and it's with members only I
don't know but ours is members only so
and there's also a slow mode on them too
States had do they have slow mode here
hearings I mean Rumble I don't think
they have the technology yet some of the
discrepancies in it uh we saw how that
unfolded Jesus behind me there's a uh
hundreds gathered to support president
Trump can you cut to the live feed
that seems like the same time
hundreds cops hold on cut to the live
feed let's take a look how many people
are there to us uh well AP cut away
because they were showing uh Trump
arriving in his plane uh no no it's live
now right Ian
it'd be feed
there's a uh
oh here we go yeah
here it is that's well that is a lot of
people yeah they showed up they showed
up
oh God hogwatch Is So back I don't know
if this is hundreds
like maybe 800
no everybody
and you're supposed to cut to one person
with the flag
I mean that would have been funny but
that would oh yeah this information on
the internet I thought we were gonna
have to set up the b-roll and cut to the
one dude with the flash I'm just trying
to you trying to do a bit I mean that
was real that was just earlier I know I
know I know I'm not spreading
disinformation on the internet that's
illegal
what the [__] was that one this is big
[Music]
[Laughter]
actually there I did two yeah
okay let's see what else we got if
there's anything else we should hit on
we've been doing yeah we are we are
technically we have to get to your
special
um presentation soon here Dan though
the Maga movie review uh yeah I mean it
is Evergreen but um we can try and make
room for it next week it I I think you
guys are going to enjoy it quite a bit
oh this is sick I love Maga movies wait
is this the one I already saw I think I
saw this oh no really I was hoping yeah
I did no it's okay don't worry it's so
did you watch it uh I didn't watch the
whole thing no okay can I show the
trailer is it gonna get claimed no this
is all unclaimed it's all it's not my
flag that's your flag to me Eli has been
told to my people uh
the the person
did the filter on this is like they have
to have a visual impairment
for the color Corrections
like what is happening the whites are so
blown out in certain shots like this
like this [__]
title screen like the spacing isn't even
consistent like the font is insane it's
not that lowercase John Schneider his
name is look at the spacing between the
T and the O and then the D and the I
it's not even consistent it's like they
moved each letter individually it's it's
so good because I like the old trail
it's my road too Arnie I'm so sad you
already knew about this
and I wasn't gonna know about it you
kidding me dude look at this [__] is
awesome because he wears a rode
microphone jacket the entire time and
then
there's a really funny sequence go to
the end I want to show Ethan this one
can I tell you something these people on
a green screen like he couldn't afford
to actually go oh yeah no like about I
would say 80 of the film is on green
screen dude you couldn't go Florida on
the street and shoot this it's over that
wasn't in the budget man it's always
fourth of July at my house
I told you what would happen the next
time you touch my flag oh God
don't get out of my yard you'll find out
and I can identify with Mr quint's
position on this map why the hell is
everybody this guy watch uh that movie
Gran Torino and was like this movie
isn't racist enough oh my God man I
literally said the oh did you really
bars verbatim I said the exact same
thing when I watched this trailer it
made it immediately made me think of
that movie and he was just like yeah the
lesson at the end of him uh learning to
respect the uh the Immigrant grids yeah
I'm losing my I said verbatim the exact
same things I was like if you watch
Grand Tour Reno and said oh well I don't
like that he uh aligned himself with the
Chinese at the end of the movie then
this is the movie for you
my favorite part of the trailer is where
he uh were like the liberal woke high
school kids are owning him yeah and then
I think he shoots one of them
spoiler alert bro oh I'm sorry I
couldn't talk about this anymore wow
this seemed like a cheeky fun little
ride but now he's killing people no no
no no this is a very serious film yeah
the liberal woke high school kids call
him the f word and he shoots one he
kills the road my kid no he doesn't kill
him he just shoots the maim not the kill
he's a patriot
gave that up a second your knee hit the
grass why don't you just leave the
country I hate it so damn much would it
surprising to know that I fought for
your flag very much Mommy why we did
this again
yeah unless you're a flag
doesn't it
dude that's gut wrenching man
to die for it's awesome because like you
know it shows the the the greatest fear
that conservatives have which is like
annoying woke high school children
bothering them you gotta kill them that
boy made me look bad
thank you everybody
no thank you thank you Assad I promise
tomorrow's show is going to be better to
borrows yeah
all right and now what you say oh
at the end of the tomorrow's show is
going to be a lot better than this one
sorry guys apologies apologies for this
horrible I like you wouldn't even let me
have that you're like nope I thought you
were talking about next week and I was
like don't be too sure
oh my throat's hurting a little bit
already oh God come on
um
[Music]
right at the end huh yeah all right all
right everybody I buttoned out because I
took the joke too far ah it's the blank
Mike Pence train now it's much better
yeah no one will know what you said well
I didn't say it
Drew all right thank you son nice to
have you hell yeah we'll see you next
week
I'd hope we have time for that but I'm
sure something crazy is going to happen
between now and then
I mean that's fire
that that is good we'll get to it guys
see you tomorrow
's show is not going to be as good as
today's
oh a little twist wow but better than
the days but better than most of them
right so you do want to wait
um actually no tomorrow we have a great
show lined up we're doing
the sour challenge tomorrow right so
yeah the actual sour challenge [__] did
you try fake face rugs sour [__]
what is a sour dude it's it sucked
so we so it's like a hot chip but for
sour but it wasn't [__] sour it was
like twenty dollars for that stupid bag
it's such a good grip so we went into
the laboratory with Sam and made our own
sour concoction that's right
influencer candy that I've had that I've
actually enjoyed and I'm not saying this
because he's my friend but Carl Jacobs
is sour gummies that are under the
feastables umbrella it was actually not
bad Peaceable stuff is pretty good kind
of hit on all of it yeah
you see Beast is suing the Beast Burger
guys I did awesome I know
I mean good
some of that was like I just I don't
know what to think because I mean he was
he was working with them for a long time
some of that was The Toxic gossip train
and by that I mean the toxicity of the
food the I was a shocked when I read
that there was so much raw food man so
much raw chicken
raw beef yeah all righty guys see you
tomorrow son have a great uh week
and uh until next time guys it's the
toxic Mike Pence train all right bring
up
[Music]
thank you